warning the following program contains
strong
zorro fanboying viewer discretion is
advised
it starts as most things doing shounen
with an epic battle
on july 27th 1998 22 years ago
shonen jump magazine published the 50th
chapter of a fresh story about a young
man
dreaming of becoming pirate king and it
was on this
hot summer day that everything changed
for the 23 year old upcoming mangaka
hiraota and his ambitious story of one
piece
because this 50th chapter not only
marked the beginning of one of the most
rememberable fights in the series
but it also set the tone for what kind
of story this was going to be
i'm of course talking about the battle
between rorano lazzoro
and dracul mihawk at the baratheon
now i think it's time to finally come
clean about something that i've been
asked about
more times than i can count o'hara what
is your favorite character
and for the longest time i didn't want
to reveal this because
i've actually no idea why but i swear i
had a good reason for this
i think well anyway let's get this out
of the way
here are my top five
number five the blind swordsman fujitora
number four the laughing skeleton brook
number three the rubber boy luffy
number two the next straw hat yamato
i bet that choice would never come back
to haunt me would it
and the undisputed number one my
favorite character in all of one piece
that no one would have ever guessed
is the legendary swordsman
zorro no no not that one thank you
the secret has finally been lifted and
yes i actually like the same character
most of you guys like as well
i know you probably expected me to say
something like i like otohimu because
the way her character is designed by oda
but [ __ ] that though otohima is actually
a pretty well written character
especially when you consider how she
anyway the reason why i always liked
zorro the most
is of course because he's by far the
coolest and most badass character in one
piece
and this is where we have to get a tad
more serious again
because what exactly does it mean for a
character to be
cool is zorro my favorite character
because he can fight well
well no that goes for countless
characters in the story
so there must be something more to it
and this brings me back to this moment
right here at the barazi a
where zorro faces off mihawk and
declares his loyalty to luffy
while admittedly there will be quite a
bunch of iconic zorro moments that we'll
be discussing in the iconic series
analysis series
trademark it is this scene right here
that made me
fall in love with soros character and
that has made me cheer for him ever
since
and so today i want to break down with
you what makes the fight
between him and mihawk i said mihawk
so special and how it was a turning
point guaranteeing the story's lasting
success
so as you know as a loyal view of the
series we'll start with a quick recap of
the scene before diving deeper into the
analysis part of this video
if you want to skip this part like kaido
skips his leg day
then you can go to the time code up here
and if you want to follow along we'll be
discussing chapters 49-52 of the manga
episode 24 of the anime or you can also
watch the updated version of the scene
in the episode of the mary
the scene takes place after sanji saving
gin
no you don't know that yet and after don
creek and his decimated crew have made
their way back from the grand line
thanks to zeff and his cooks the starved
crew starts to recover
and are rejoicing at being saved and
having survived the horrors of the grand
line
somehow making it back into the east
blue alive
amidst their joy however creek tells
them that they will actually return to
the groundline
and upon seeing the understandable lack
of motivation of his crew to return to
the place they were almost killed at
he shoots one of his men who dares
criticizing his decision
he then declares that he will be taking
the bharatiya ship as well
since the cooks there are easy to defeat
despite the fact that they had saved his
life
when his men start attacking the
floating restaurant however
the heavily damaged gigantic ship they
arrived on
is suddenly cut in half
amidst the confusion that ensues nami
steals the mary to travel home
and while zoro thinks that it's not
really worth pursuing her
both luffy and usop disagree usop
wanting the marry back
and luffy insisting on making nami then
navigator
zorro agrees despite being a bit annoyed
by luffy's attitude here
however when he and usa prepare to set
sail
mihawk arrives at the scene
zorro is in absolute disbelief that the
man he was looking for
has now actually arrived right before
his eyes
as it turns out it was mihawk who had
attacked creek's fleet
and had chased after them simply to kill
some time
upon hearing this one of the greek
pirates attempts to shoot him
but mihawk easily deflects the bullet
with his mighty black sword euro
and while some of the pirates seem to
think that they simply missed
zorro immediately understands what has
happened here
and he addresses mihawk thank you and he
addresses mihawk directly
he tells him about his goal to take his
place as the strongest swordsman in the
world
and challenges him to a duel seeing the
chance to fulfill his dream
right here right now mihawk however
doesn't seem to be particularly
impressed by this
he gets slowly off his ship approaches
zorro and calls him a weakling
telling him that if he truly were a
great swordsman
the difference in their powers would be
obvious to him without the need to cross
blades
zorro however insists and mihawks
humiliates him even more by picking a
small
pocketknife as his weapon of choice
stating that it would be inappropriate
to use his big sword to hunt a mere
rabbit also
referencing the east blue as the weakest
of the four seas
not capable of producing any notable
fighters
he then uses a small knife to stop soros
fierce attacks who in disbelief about
this striking difference in power
first thinks of his promise to korina
and then luffy
and redoubles his efforts mihawk
realizing his mental anguish
asks him what is burdening him and
finally stabs him
right in the chest while everyone is
visibly shocked at the devastating blow
the biggest surprise comes from mihawk
as zorro simply stands there
with a knife in his chest not making any
attempt to withdraw
in this moment mihawk's annoyed
impression
changes for the first time and you can
see his respect for zorro grow
only now he actually asks zoro to state
his name
promising to remember it and as a
gesture of respect to a fellow swordsman
he tells zoro that he will fight him
with the world's strongest blades
in this last standoff zorro unleashes
his ultimate attack on mihawk
[Music]
but it's not enough
he sheds the water chimonji no i said
wado ichimonji and he turns around
towards mihawk presenting him his open
chest
prepared to receive his death blow
mihawk
is visibly pleased with zoro's brave
gesture and slashes his chest open
noting that zorro shouldn't rush his own
death after
seeing his first mate apparently killed
in front of his eyes
luffy charges against mihawk full of
rage while johnny and yosaku
dive into the sea to save zorro instead
of fighting luffy however
mihawk tells him that zoro isn't dead
and properly introduces himself for the
very first time
urging sorrow to become stronger and
face him once again
he then asks luffy for his goal and once
luffy answers
kaizoku mihawk acknowledges that this
will be an
even more difficult task than surpassing
him
in that moment zorro regains
consciousness
coughing up blood he lifts his blade
into the air and makes an oath to luffy
[Music]
now looking more than pleased mihawk
turns around to leave without paying any
more attention to the don creek pirates
who he was looking for in the first
place
he tells luffy that him and zorro make a
great team and that he wishes to meet
them again in the future
honestly no matter how often i watch or
read the scene here
it always gives me shivers i think it
just has this sense of tingling
atmosphere that i love
so much in great stories now while the
last scene surrounding blackbeard's
speech on jaya was made so special
mostly by the incredible amount of
symbolism it carried
one might think that this moment here is
made amazing mostly by the fighting
choreography between zoro and mihawk
thank you but what i really think this
scene here
excels at is something that i think is
quite often overlooked in one piece
dialogue the conversations and dialogue
in the scene are fantastic and do a
wonderful job of enhancing the other
artistic elements in this moment
and so i really want to talk about this
in a second first though actually let's
do
start with symbolism once again since
there is a lot of interesting stuff
packed in here that i think will give us
a good grasp of what's going on
let's start with something i noticed for
the first time here when rereading the
scene for this video
both zorro and mihawk have the theme of
religion
incorporated into their characters for
zorro
this clearly is buddhism as we can see
with his technique sunsen sekai
three thousand worlds for the very first
time in the scene here
it's a pattern that follows zoro
throughout the series something that my
friend joyboy covers in this video here
that will be linked in the description
below so make sure to check that out
also jb if you're watching this thanks
so much for putting up with my wacky
ideas buddy
i rewatched the intro to this video way
more than i probably should have
now next to zoro's connections to
buddhism mihawk's character
also is surrounded by a number of
religious symbols
however in his case it is christianity
not buddhism that is referenced
in fact mihawk's entire design strongly
resembles that of the stereotypical
spanish inquisitor
or at least a very religious spanish
swordsman
his hat and the golden cross on his
chest that contains the small pocket
knife he stabbed zorro with
as well as his facial hair make this
connection quite obvious
further mihawk's ship is literally a
giant coffin with a large cross for a
mast
that also resembles the hilt of a sword
uru so in essence we have two swordsmen
representing two religions in the scene
and you could of course spin this even
further and say that shanks is also
swordsman who represents
another religion with nordic mythology
but i think we're kind of losing track
of things here a little bit
so let's get back to topic next to the
religious aspect i think mihawk swords
also have another symbolic meaning here
respect
mihawk uses his pocket knife the
smallest weapon he carries to face
sorrow at first
showing just how little he thinks of him
and how unworthy he is of facing the
strongest swordsman in the worlds
mihok is a quite proud character after
all
however once soro proves his
determination and honor to him
mihawk switches from his smallest weapon
to yoru
the mightiest blade in the world
symbolizing that zorro has now gained
mihawk's full respect as a swordsman
and is worthy of facing the blade of the
strongest swordsman as well
and speaking of swordsman of course
there's also a lot of symbolism
regarding the bushido
the path of the warrior that both mihawk
and zorro follow
and we'll get into this a bit more when
looking at the dialogue
but zorro not stepping back after
getting stabbed
offering his chest and displaying honor
respect and loyalty
show that zorro and mihawk are in fact
following the same path
and that mihawk can respect and accept
sorrow as a fellow swordsmaster
and i feel that oda goes even further
than that because this scene here
is the basis for the entire growth
sorrow has as a fighter over the course
of the story
by offering multiple parallels to mihawk
here
for instance mihawk uses a tiny blade
here to fight against someone he sees
unworthy
zorro uses the small sepuku blade to cut
down the unworthy samurai in the flower
capital in wano
mihawk cuts up don creek's ship at the
baratier and
zoro cuts up a ship when returning after
the time skip
muhag also called zorro a frog in a well
here basically implying that he's
ignorant of the world at large
and sorrow does the very same thing to
one of the fishmen on fishman island
and all of this has of course happened
after mihawk became zoro's mentor and
taught him for two years
these references to the scene here at
the baratier symbolize
just how much sorrow has grown and how
much closer he is now to mihawk
meanwhile i feel like the entire
religious aspect between them might
finally make the difference in zorro
surpassing his mentor
in the end this scene here tells us that
will is even more important than power
as mihawk expects zoro to surpass him to
do his burning will
but luffy also carries the symbol here
as his battle with don creek
is also a clear sign that a strong will
is
way more important than physical power
and luffy and zoro actually share
something else in this scene
they show us what true leadership and
loyalty
should look like luffy and zorro have
the exact
opposite dynamic from don creek and his
mem
the way luffy treats zoro and vice versa
is built on trusting each other and
believing in each other's dreams
all things that distinguish the straw
hats from most other pirates throughout
the story
and you can even include nami and sanji
into this
nami steals the mary to look after her
home village however
deeply regretting having to leave luffy
behind and betraying him
meanwhile sanji who was opposed to
joining the crew
is finally convinced to follow luffy as
his captain
by his and zoro's actions here this
starts with
zoro's incredible fight against mihawk
and ends with luffy's victory over don
creek
and finally i think that the entire
sequence here serves as a symbol for
what is about to come in the story
the goal that the straw hats are heading
towards the grand line
so far we've encountered a number of
villains that caused some trouble for
our heroes
but never truly were threatening or
pushing them to the edge
this however is different the enormous
ship of don creek
coming back from the grand line where he
lost an entire fleet
gives us a feeling of what lies ahead
and it clearly doesn't feel like it will
be the tropical adventure we've had so
far
and when mihawk arrives at the scene and
we learn that he was the one who sank
almost 50 of creek's ships simply to
kill some time
we understand that the people the straw
hats will be facing on the grand line
will be on a completely different level
after all mihawk's ship is a literal
coffin
and the grand line is also known as the
pirate's graveyard
[Music]
something that i think is very
interesting to look at as well in the
scene
are the framing and composition here as
mentioned at the beginning
these chapters are from 1998 and from a
time where oda's art style
was still very much in its infancy now
that doesn't mean of course that it's
bad or anything but
comparing the chapters nowadays with the
early chapters of one piece
you can definitely tell that drawing
every day for over 20 years
helps at least a little bit to improve
thus the characters back in the day
still looked a bit more static and
simple and the artwork lacked some of
the spatial and ambient feel that oda
manages to integrate in most of his
panels today
there are three things that are quite
notably great here already however
first oda already displays a liking
towards gigantism here
this panel of creek's flagship towering
over the bharatiya restaurant
is fantastic and gives the entire scene
an
otherworldly and epic feel something
very fitting for foreshadowing the grand
line and how it will overshadow the east
blue
secondly the artwork here already has
quite decent framing and composition
the way the ship is later cut in two
with the bharati as a reference point
for its size
and the way that the ship's figurehead
seems to be in pain here
are wonderful details in the shots and
thirdly while i never shy away from
mentioning that there are other mangaka
out there that outperform oda in terms
of battle art and the overall battle
system
oda has a unique sense for creating
drama and conveying
feelings through body language and
dialogue in his scenes
[Applause]
they almost feel like conversations in
themselves
thus moments like mihawk stopping zaro's
three blades with his pocket knife
the powerful moment before he stabs
sorrow or mihawk
actually cutting zorro down all have
great composition
and the line of events is portrayed in a
way that builds emotion and stakes
very fast for the audience also i feel
like the updated version of the anime
does a particularly great job here
updating oda's work and giving it a more
modern and dynamic feel
okay but now let's finally look at the
dialogue in the scene which i think
brings all of these other elements
together
and truly makes the scene unique and
iconic
before we can get into the fantastic
conversation between zorro mihawk and
luffy
i quickly want to direct your attention
to this panel here however
when nami tells johnny and yosaku that
she and the straw hats will meet again
if they're truly linked by fate
i think this is a very powerful line by
nami here in a number of ways
because as we know luffy and co end up
meeting her again in the end alright
but they don't just randomly encounter
her because of chance or fate
but because of luffy's will to make her
part of the crew
and save her from a misery that we can
see when nami wishes to be free
with tears streaming down her face after
leaving
so it's really not about the straw hats
being pushed forward by
fate as many people seem to believe as
was for instance the case with naruto or
ichigo in the end
but i rather think it is oda's way of
saying very early on in the story
that luffy doesn't care about destiny
and fate but
that his own strong will allows him to
forge his own path ahead and
overcome fate that's why i found it so
important to include this part into my
analysis as well
and i think it also nicely translates
into the dialogue between mihawk and
zorro
because mihawk acknowledges zorro for
his will and determination to surpass
him and
not because he was always destined to
become the strongest
when zoro refuses to step back after
mihawk nearly pierces his heart
he tells mihawk that if he stepped back
right now
he would lose his dream and honor as a
swordsman and would rather die
zorro proves his strong will here to
achieve his dream and it is this will
that changes mihawk's perception of him
as he says here your strength is not
often seen in this world
clearly it's not soros physical strength
so for the very first time in this
moment i think
oda presents will or more specifically
strength of will
as the most important quality for his
characters that counts
way more than raw physical ability and
even more than
faith and ultimately with the
introduction of haki it becomes clear
that willpower literally surpasses
both of these things you can use your
willpower to drastically increase your
fighting power
and you can even use it to glimpse ahead
into the future
and change your own fate i'm honestly
not sure if oda
already had the concept of haki plan out
at this early point in the story
and if i had to bet i would probably say
no
but it is painfully obvious that will
was gonna be
the essential driving force in the story
right from the start
similarly mihawk also recognizes luffy's
will to strive to become pirate king
without a hint of the mocking he had for
zorro at the start
of course soros fight played an
important part here
but i think that luffy being a conqueror
hockey user
probably already radiated a strong sense
of will
and it is probably also at this moment
here that mihawk remembers the story
that shanks told him of how he lost his
arm
seeing luffy's powers and the straw hats
i think we can
even see this moment of recognition in
this panel here
where luffy first stretches his arm but
i think the dialogue does even more here
though
as especially in the japanese but also
in the english version
the words that mihawk uses to address
sorrow more and more reflect his change
in attitude
and his rising level of respect for him
his speech pattern switches from this
by his first name and challenges him to
surpass him
i think to some degree this is due to
mihawk yearning for a true challenge
after losing shanks
but i also believe that as a master
swordsman and sharing zoro's values and
beliefs
he has chosen zorro as worthy to follow
in his footsteps
and keep these values alive and defend
their craft against non-believers
if you want to bring it back to the
religious theme
and so i believe it makes for an even
starker contrast when mihawk is finally
approached by don creek again
as his face completely reverts from an
excited glow
to disgust and annoyance and he slashes
the ship once more
before disappearing because i feel with
this
he contrasts the difference between
luffy and creek before their battle even
begins
now last but not least i of course want
to address zoro's speech to luffy
which is the second of my favorite zorro
moments in the scene
after luffy has displayed true care and
fear for his first mate's life
even shedding a rare tear zaro now
publicly acknowledges and honors luffy
for the very first time in the story
zorro clearly has realized luffy's true
love and respect for him
as he apologizes for worrying his
captain he declares that he will never
lose again
and that he will stand by the next
pirate king making clear that he fully
believes in luffy and his dreams
just as luffy believes in him as far as
i can remember it's the only time we
ever see zorro cry in the story
outside of queen's death and it makes
the scene
just the more impactful for seeing the
otherwise stoic
and composed samurai this emotional and
vulnerable
i think it's really what makes this
scene even better when you come back to
it later
and so in just about three chapters
zorro has
established himself as the most
honorable loyal and determined person
that luffy could have ever wished for as
his right hand man
and the reasons why i love his character
so much
this scene serves as a basis for so
many other wonderful zaro moments in the
story and it's an important element for
making him a deeper and more complex
character
and thus distinguishes him from most
other strong characters
it's a moment that is incredibly
important for his and luffy's
development
and their fights are ultimately the
reason why sanji decides to join them
and follow his own dream as well
another moment with zorro i really liked
in the scene is when nami is leaving
zaro thinks it's a bad idea following
her and getting in trouble for it
but he follows his captain anyway this
is wonderfully referenced during the
whole cake island arc where he also is
skeptical about following sanji
but ends up respecting luffy's decision
anyway
as a result when the straw hats chase
after nami towards arlong park
we get another one of my favorite
moments in the story
luffy saving nami and giving her his hat
and so we'll be looking at that in the
next video so
stay tuned for that and don't forget to
leave me your feedback and ideas for the
next videos in the series
thanks guys peace